[Applause]
joyeux both you and Partners in Health
had spent decades in various
battlegrounds battling epidemics perhaps
the context you could give us a couple
examples of that work yeah so Partners
in Health is a global nonprofit that is
then 30 years old we started famously in
Haiti and a squatter settlement people
who were displaced and when we talked to
them they wanted health care and
education houses jobs and that has
informed our work that proximity to
people who are suffering when you think
about health care in the poor there is
always disproportionate suffering for
people who have been historically
marginalized like our communities that
we serve in Haiti and so we've always
tried to provide health care for the
poorest people on earth and we were
launched into an international dialogue
about whether that was possible for
drug-resistant tuberculosis for HIV
indeed for surgery for cancer for mental
health for non communicable diseases and
we believe it's possible and it is part
of the basic human right to care
so when kovin started we saw this
immediately as a threat to the health of
people who were the poorest and partners
in health now works in eleven countries
five on the African continent Latin
America and the Caribbean as well as the
former Soviet Union and we immediately
prepared to scale up testing contact
tracing treatment care and then saw that
it wasn't being done in the United
States in that way and in fact we were
just sitting passively waiting for
people to get sick and treat them in
hospital and that message got to the
governor of Massachusetts and we started
supporting the state to do
tracing fork ovid with the very idea
that this would help us identify and
resource the communities that were most
vulnerable so it's really quite ironic
that that this these decades of
experience in the developing world and
elsewhere that that has now really been
seen as a crucial need to bring to the
US and especially to bring your
expertise around contact tracing so so
talk a bit about contact tracing why
does it matter so much and what would I
don't know a perfect contact tracing set
up look like well first I want to say
that you want to always in any type of
illness you want to do prevention and
diagnosis and treatment and care that is
what comprehensive approaches look like
and that care piece to us is about the
provision of social support and material
support to allow people to get the care
they need so that might be
transportation it might be food so when
you look at that comprehensive approach
for an infectious disease part of
prevention is knowing where the disease
is spreading and how it's spreading and
in whom it's spreading so that resources
can be disproportionately put to the
highest risk areas so contact tracing is
a staple of public health and what it
means is that every time a new person is
diagnosed with kovat or any infectious
disease then you investigate and
enumerate the people they've been in
contact with and call those contacts and
say you've been exposed or talked to
them you've been exposed these are the
things you need to know first of all how
are you do you need care yourself and
facilitating that second of all these
are the informations you need to know to
keep yourself safe about quarantine
about prevention and again this would be
with any infectious disease from Ebola
to cholera to a sexually transmitted
disease like HIV and then we say okay
knowing what you know do you have the
means to protect yourself because often
the most vulnerable do not have the
means to protect themselves so that is
also where this resource component comes
in and where equity is so critical to
making this disease stop and also
getting the information and the
resources to people who need them the
most
and in epidemic the people who need them
the most the most vulnerable as you say
are probably also that's where the
disease is spreading a lot of it's in
everyone's interests to be this is not
you're not just making this sort of
wonderful equity in moral point that
we've got to help these people it's
actually in all of our interest right
yes yes we are one humanity and any
disease any infectious disease that is
spreading is a threat to all of us and
that is one of the pieces there's the
moral imperative
there's the epidemiologic imperative
that if you can't control these diseases
everywhere that it's a threat anywhere
and so as we look to the kind of society
we want to live in good health is
something that gives us all so much
return our on our investment
now some countries were able to use
contact tracing almost to shut down the
pandemic before it before it took off in
that country the u.s. was unable to do
that and some people have taken the view
that therefore contract racing became
irrelevant that the strategy was
mitigation shut everything down
you've argued against that that even in
a process of lockdown that actually
contact tracing plays a key role help us
understand like the scale when there's a
lot of cases the scale of tracing both
cases and everyone David they may have
been in contact with and their contacts
it quickly gets to a huge it's what what
sort of workforce do you do you need to
make a difference at this moment in
where the u.s. is that
it's massive I mean the scale is massive
and we should not take that lightly and
we don't Partners in Health I mean we
are willing to try to figure this out
and I always feel that if we could stop
a bola in some of the poorest countries
in the world of course we ought to do it
here and was it too late when there were
28 thousand deaths and Ebola sure it was
it's always too late we should have
started earlier but it's not too late to
have an impact and so there's three
aspects of timing and scale first is the
earlier you start the better right and
that's what we saw in Rwanda they went
from early testing and contact tracing
the first two cases entered into the
country in on March 15 and in one month
because of contact tracing isolation and
plenty of testing they had held that
case rate to 134 people it's remarkable
it's remarkable in the state of Georgia
where is home to the CDC similar
population size about 12 million from
the first two cases in the first month
those cases became 4,400 cases and in
the country of Belgium a similar
population those two cases became 7,400
so you do have to make scale to stop
this but the earlier you do it the more
benefits there are to your society and
also to the other people who need
medical services women who are pregnant
people who need their fracture repaired
because services themselves in the
United States have been you know really
hampered by this huge amount of Kovan so
so the first point is it's it's always
late but it's never too late
why because vulnerable populations are
sitting ducks and so imagine if one of
your contacts was a nursing assistant
who worked in a nursing home we know
that one nursing assistant can spread it
throughout a nursing home and is it
important to identify that person as a
contact and
sure that he or she is able to remain
quarantined that is critical and so it's
hard to say well it's not worth it if
it's just one person to person every
life matters and all of their contacts
in the community of that person matters
as well so that's one thing the second
about scale is people need jobs right
now and they want to be part of a
solution and some of the frustration we
see the anti lockdown movement is really
out of anger and frustration and feeling
what can we do and so this gives people
this feeling that they're part of a
solution and can provide thousands of
jobs and then third I would say for us
to reopen our schools our churches our
workplaces we have to know where the
virus is spreading so that we don't just
continue on this path and so contact
tracing provides the platform to control
but also to see outbreaks in real time
popping up and then respond promptly so
there are many reasons that we have to
bring this to scale now even though it
is tardy
so especially as we have this pressure
to go back to work like a contact
tracing has to be part of that strategy
or we're just inviting another disaster
in in a few weeks time whatever whatever
you make of what's happened during this
mitigation process exactly exactly
exactly and so that's such an important
part Chris and something that we are
just really keen to look at the United
States in a different way what are the
long-term public health infrastructures
that we need to protect us for the
second way the third wave and in the
future for future pandemics Whitney and
you know to that point I there's a
question actually out there from one of
our anonymous anonymous community
members actually about why contact
tracing isn't already part of our public
health system it seems like it it does
make a lot of sense it's a way to
mitigate the spread of disease because
you speak a little bit to that mm-hmm I
think many people have said and
I'm not a politician but that our
American health care infrastructure is
built on treatment and not prevention
it's built on procedures and not keeping
people well and some of that was driven
by profit and some of that was driven by
need but I think we need to rethink how
we deliver care in this environment
there is some fear and suspicion about
privacy and contract async treating how
can we build trust in the process yeah
that's a great question and I think
there's fear about privacy and part of
it comes from the idea of what contact
tracing is and I think that's why we
feel strongly is if you lead with the
idea that it's care and it's trying to
get resources and information and help
to people it seems very different than
just oh who's sick and who you know
who's a threat and so fundamentally and
that's why we're so pleased to be at
this Ted TED talk today is it's about
communication right it's not about
surveillance it's about communication
and care and support that's one thing
and we'll you know we'll be hearing from
our colleagues on the tech side there's
ways to to add tech even to care that it
can be a resource for caring and
communication but there are ways to
protect people's privacy and also to
provide care and Public Health has many
laws attached to it this is all done
within the constructs of our state
public health laws and so I think some
of the communication around this is how
do we take care of each other
how do we take care of the most
vulnerable and if we frame contact
tracing as care I think that starts a
different kind of conversation mmm
so joy can you just talk in a bit more
detail about what it is that you're
advising Massachusetts to
in terms of contact tracing it was a
sense of the scale of it yeah so the
scale thank you you know we are able now
to make about 10,000 calls a day to
contacts so every new case that comes in
the case is investigated by someone on
the phone and then those investigation
means writing down the the names and the
phone numbers of the persons you've been
in contact with for the time you were
sick and a couple days before and with
those numbers than the contact tracers
and that's what we really redoubled the
work force and really expanded more than
doubled to support the Department of
Public Health to do that contact tracing
so we have 1,700 people employed
full-time with benefits to call those
contacts and say are you ok this is the
information you need and then and I
think this is the critical piece when
someone doesn't have the information
then we have another cadre of people we
call the resource care coordinators who
help that person that contact to do the
things they need to do to protect
themselves it might be food delivery it
might be filing for unemployment
benefits it might be trying to get them
a medical care or a test that piece is
the care piece and that is what turns
social distancing from very regressive
look at me and my beautiful house social
distancing to something that's
progressive and paying attention to
those who need the resources so the
scale is massive with 1,700 employees
hired to do this but they are connected
with local community food banks and
churches and facilities and and and
primary health care centers as well
thank you so much joy